能力と知恵の開発 このこれを私はこの英語でレイテンという単語を使いましたけど
これは潜在的ということでね
心には本来すごい無茶能力があるんです
過去を思い出そうといえば
もう何百 何万 何光年でも思い出せるんですよ
だからもう能力はあるんですけど
これがもうループの問題でね
感情でもめちゃくちゃ猛毒で壊してますからね
心の力は巨大です まあ最後になりましたから早く終わります
妄想を停止することですよ
簡単に 妄想を停止するんだからといって理性紛いなくなるとかね
思考もできなくなったとか
学校で教えることもできなくなったとか
とんでもない話ですよ
だから論理的な思考は一応ループを作りますから
それはまあ別にあります
妄想を停止する訓練で無駄な思考のループが切断するんですよ
あの恐ろしい すごい 我々
我は本当は天才なんですけどね
今はもう天才のところじゃないんだからね
すごい力 巨大な力あるのに
何一つできないでしょうに
だからそこであの妄想のループを切断すればいいんです
思考停止訓練で それだけで人間に巨大な力を発揮することができるんです
妄想が減る分 頭は有効にスムーズに動く
働くんです 無能で悩んでいることはこれでなくなるんです
真理の発見もできる だから思考停止っていうのは
このヴィパッサナー瞑想で言ってる作法なんですよ
たったそれだけ 実況中継するだけ
たったそれだけでこれぐらいのことは得られます
だから中途半端でいい加減で生ぬるくやるなよと
だって妄想のループというのは生ぬるくないんだから
これは強烈ですから だから強烈なものは切断するためにもそれぐらい力が必要なんです
そんなところで話は終わると思います